let's go next to our caller from the six
for six
area code who's calling from six for six
today uh hi my name is Steve I'm in New
York hey Steve on the this is actually I
had no idea what your last caller would
say but this is resonating trust me with
what I was thinking about you had about
a two-week stretch where you talked
almost every day about how you were
getting screwed over by YouTube right as
they were D monetizing all your videos
yep I'm curious what do you think about
the long-term future of independent
media on YouTube it's one thing to be
able to set up a patreon page where
people can directly send directly
support media today that's a value right
however if YouTube is making it harder
for people to find your to find your
videos or other independent media
there's going to be a point where the
membership would start to fall off or if
people I've start to see that people
just don't seem to be starting new
YouTube channels because they they're
not they're not able to make money off
them yeah well YouTube has delayed how
quickly you can start monetization and
that can definitely be a disincentive to
even start a channel I don't remember
what the requirements are but until your
channel is of a certain size or audience
you can't monetize it at all I mean
listen that this is a very broad and big
question on the one hand as I've said if
you like a show you should support it
directly because the instability of the
revenue sources from platforms like
YouTube makes it difficult to count on
that so you need you know direct support
but you're pointing out something which
is even monetization aside if YouTube
makes it more difficult to find my
content the number of people who sign up
for direct memberships is a direct
function of the number of people that
are consuming the content in general and
if YouTube reduces that by burying us
we're also going to get less financial
support that is direct so this this is
like a massive issue to be dealt with in
the short term the audience I have I
implore to support the work we're doing
directly if the algorithmic stuff gets
worse over the long run we'll have to
sort of deal with that when we get to it
and my approach is diversification we're
we'll be announcing some new platforms
soon that the show will be on and the
goal is if we are less reliant on
YouTube both for revenue and traffic
then we're just going to be hedging our
bets and spreading our risk in a way
that is going to hopefully sustain us
yeah it feels to me like it's in the
next couple of years there's got to be
some kind of competition for YouTube
right but that's the problems the whole
internet now that it started out as
something that was very open and it
seemed like you could break the hold of
corporate media yeah but now it's down
to control from just a few companies
that's right and particularly this
doesn't directly have a thing to do with
politics but I I watched a lot of music
related videos on YouTube and if you do
music criticism you can you can't play
that music on your on your video India
if you want to get monetized and that
just seems completely absurd yeah I
don't disagree with you and this is this
is you know we've dealt with this with
debates as well points all well made and
ones we will we will continue talking
about for sure I really appreciate the
phone call I am out of time for calls
and I do apologize for everybody who's
holding that I did not get to but we
will take calls again and I look forward
to hearing from you then we will take a
quick break and be back right after this